let's talk about how dark things are
actually getting
so let's step into this one from cnbc
congressional panel investigating
january 6 insurrection demands records
from facebook twitter and other tech
firms so here we go you may have heard
that the january 6 committee submit uh
submitted a letter to all these
different government agencies demanding
information on basically everybody in
the trump government as well as a large
number of activists
who are just
i mean scott pressler is the most
pressing example he's a guy who
registers republicans the vote he cleans
up garbage and they said they wanted
every every communication from the
government to him going back to april
first of 2020 into january 20th of 2021.
this guy has nothing to do with any of
it
in my understanding he wasn't even in dc
during on january 6th
but this is their overreach and now it's
coming to the big tech firms which is
what we expected when we had jack
bosovich here who was on this list you
know the general idea we were talking
about is they'll eventually take it from
the government to social media companies
now all of these big tech firms who we
know are biased are going to start going
after trump supporters and activists
they're i'm willing to bet if you're
like some mid-level trump supporter your
communications your dms will probably
get leaked because they're going to
demand it and why why would facebook
twitter or google say no they're going
to be like well you know it's very
important we help out here you go well
look at look at how the government tax
forms for all these rich people got
leaked all of a sudden
biden is talking about going after rich
people with his tax efforts oh and also
talking about throwing tons of money at
the irs
magically pro publica gets a dump of the
tax for the tax records for a lot of
famous rich people and then starts
writing about it now you know
it's
oh remember we weren't supposed to talk
about the deep state oh deep state
doesn't exist until a guy from the new
york times writes a book and says the
deep state that deep say exists and it's
good it's a good thing because it's on
our side you know let's uh let me read a
little bit from here we got this from
cnbc they say the house select committee
investigating january 6
said friday it's demanding a trove of
records from 15 social media companies
including facebook twitter google and a
slew of pro-trump platforms the requests
for records stretching back to the
spring of 2020 are related to the spread
of misinformation efforts to overturn
the 2020 election or prevent the
certification of the results domestic
violent extremism or and foreign
influence in the 2020 election the
committee said in a press release
they're also looking into policy changes
that the social media companies adopted
or failed to adopt regarding the spread
of violent extremism misinformation and
foreign malign influence that includes
decisions on banning material from
platforms and contacts with law
enforcement and other government
entities the press release said the
committee's latest requests further
underscore the role of social media on
the capital attack blah blah blah blah
blah they
blamed parlor but it was actually
facebook where people were were getting
together and scheduling and planning for
the uh for for january 6. so uh the
coordination coordination and collusion
i think is obvious and now
what's the chances that these companies
just turn over all this data and
everyone who is anti-establishment all
of a sudden has the worst possible
things they've ever said taken out of
context plastered all over the internet
every story possible and then what
happens next after that is the financial
institution starts saying oh oh oh geez
these stories yep gotta ban them well
financial institutions already are doing
some of that they did it too
i was gonna say one of the one of the
republican senate candidates in delaware
oh okay we can't we're not gonna allow
you we're gonna we're gonna shut down
your bank account
we're gonna you know you got paypal
doing the same thing all these companies
but yes that is that's an enormous
insane uh stasi like uh you know
overreach of gov of government into
basically the lives of absolutely
everybody
yeah this is and you're right it's not
just but it's not just the they could
they could leak oh you you know you're
having an affair on your wife somebody's
having you know oh you just you send a
dirty joke used anything they want they
can use against you with that and
unfortunately we all and i've certainly
followed this category we've all spent
years
posting absolutely everything on social
media and then and beyond that they also
know who your friends are so even if
you've not done anything wrong
they can go after your family members
okay you know you're you're you know
you're 50 years old you got kids who are
in their 20s oh you've never done you've
never even done speeding
but your kids oh well they've done
something wrong so hey we're going after
the kids now
there's that is that's just the most
broad insanity thing i've ever heard
government do it's very clear the path
that we're on where we're going and at a
certain point i'm kind of just like
i don't know what do we do do we just
you know kick back put your feet up and
wait for the tsunami to crash over in
public but you got to be super subtle
about how you change the system quietly
like how like by building technology
that yeah makes it building culture yeah
yeah like fetiverse projects things
where things that can't be censored or
that aren't censored by nature things
that are decentralized
stuff like that you know cryptography
and
cryptocurrency that's why they hate they
hate crypto so much they freak out about
it because that really does you know put
a uh
well they can they can
they can't monitor where your money goes
no they can't and but i mean but i mean
that's depending on which one you use if
you use like monero or zcash but bitcoin
is fully public right and they can
easily track all of it but i mean this
follows this follows chokepoint
you know when chokepoint went after when
after the the other
i guess what the gun companies and other
stuff and
one after drugs you can't carry more
than ten thousand dollars of cash on you
because oh you might be right might be
making a drug deal then when they found
that people were carrying nine they cut
it back to eight
because they don't want you to you know
it's like we don't want you carrying
cash because you might actually buy
something we don't approve of and so now
if we catch you with eight thousand and
one dollars in your car
we can take it all yep civil asset
forfeiture they steal your money and you
don't get it back amazing yeah i wonder
how that would play out if you're like
running like a burger shop and you have
like your day daily cash from the right
from the tails you're going to the bank
with it and they're like that's a bank
they stop you outside the bank and
they're like you're going to go buy
drugs
they're like you're like you're holding
the deposit thing open
dude we are living in the nightmare
dystopia and it's only getting worse
every day and the only re and i guess
when you're a frog in a pot and the pot
starts slowly coming to a boil people
just don't know and don't care but i i
people need to stop and just think about
a few things what
is it is it shocking to you if i told
you that you have a a a a serial number
right you're with the government for
your person
not for me nothing nothing i i mean my
my level of shock is
kind of gone up a lot you know like what
it takes to shock i think if i went home
and i found police cars surrounding my
home i'd probably be surprised by like i
don't think that reaches shock isn't it
a crazy idea when you realize that like
every single person in the u.s is
serialized with a specific number that
identifies you every citizen yeah it's
like something i remember i'd grow up
and i'd see like movies where people
would get numbers and stuff like that
and how wrong and bad it was and then
it's like but we've been doing this
since what is like 1916 or something
social security numbers not unique music
fdr
so when was that 30s 30s yeah yeah so so
if you want to do anything in this
country you know almost anything you
need a social security number you need
to be registered with the government now
you've got new york city saying you need
to you need a photo id state issued in
order to get access to any of these
buildings it's weird like we go to the
restaurant hey i want to get i want to
get carry out sorry you can't come in no
no no no carry that's okay there's
nobody if you can't come in the building
unless you show your id no no no no no
the law exempts carry out oh okay yeah
yeah i don't know why apparently if you
have covet but you're only going to be
in for carryout you can't cough on
people or something also i learned
something really interesting is that
when uh when you when you first walk in
you're wearing the mask because kovid
sits high
but when you sit down you're underneath
it i'm kidding by the way i have no idea
what that policy is it's like you walk
into a restaurant i was talking to a
restaurant on the phone and i was like
they were like oh you've got to wear
masks regardless of vaccination status
and i was like okay and i was like but
then when i sit down i can take it off
they're like yes and i was like does
that make sense and the guy was like
i don't know they just make me do it and
i'm like
yo that's ridiculous dude like uh
whatever man people just keep they
people just follow along they march
along with all this stuff well i mean
you look at australia right now it's not
just march alone but i mean they're all
locked in their homes again i mean i've
lost track i saw somebody post a chart
of how many lockdowns australia has had
since since covet this is the they're
going on the eighth i think
seventh or eighth year oh youtube's mad
at us right now yeah they're giving us
trouble yeah so i'm i'm checking the
feed and i'm seeing it keeps cutting out
yeah we've got full internet we've got
our internet's
what spicy things are we talking about
might be us i think ben and andreas were
going to work on the internet today so
there was some issues no no i'm looking
at the connection we're solid
interesting we have a solid high-speed
connection right now
yeah i'll start singing uh avenue q for
you know maybe they'd be happy if we
talk about that talk about porn you know
i just want to i i just i do there is
something that needs to be said though
it needs to be said ian okay you people
need to hear this oh here we go
mark zuckerberg is such a good guy he's
just so fun you know
he's just co-opted by the corporation
right now
dorothy's also now he moved in from the
i've got the crazy like 400 mile beard
into i'm now dating supermodels so he is
going through a little bit of a phase
midlife crisis yeah he got all the
career stuff out of the way he's just
he's he's a figurehead for twitter you
know he left the company he's doing
square square's doing really well and
then they brought him back because they
needed someone to take responsibility i
guess so he i don't even know why he
does it
i don't i don't make sense to me the
dude's got he's a billionaire like what
does he i get that he's maybe he feels
like just by still having a tether with
it he can still kind of make it keep it
from going totally insane but
when a company buys you out man that's
their company now it's not it's not his
company anymore so yeah it's like a skin
suit
yeah but you know look
actions speak louder than words i
suppose uh did you see when jack dressy
tweeted out rothbard the anatomy of the
state like all the libertarians and
handicaps were like they're like
high-fiving each other and they're like
yeah actually they're probably freaking
out like our friend luke was like what's
happening
jack dorsey's nose but uh but i think
some of this is a lot of what we see now
on social media from famous people is
them just screwing with us and i mean i
think because they know they that it
changes the narrative and everybody
talks about them again that's what he
does on twitter yeah that's what tim
does it's
it just screws at people oh i love
social media it's like the andy kaufman
but to be fair i'm just following i'm
just uh following orders michael malus
you know oh yeah michael malus is a pro
i tweeted uh joe biden is the greatest
president of this or any generation and
then i waited a few minutes and then i
replied why aren't you retweeting this
and it got it got like a thousand
reviews or something it got like two
thousand replies but the funny thing is
like
i'll tell you exactly why i did a tweet
like that
because you have establishment left
activists and how do they respond to
that tweet
i said something very very complimentary
to joe biden but the implication is
it's
sarcasm
so the interesting thing is that
establishment uh democrat type activists
completely ignore tweets like that and
that i do that it kind of it kind of
proves a point
you know there was uh uh when i when i
when i was tweeting about vaccine medics
being wrong i get all of these
establishment democrat activists being
like
you're crazy you're wrong there will be
medical exemptions everyone's got to
pitch in and then when i called all of
these restaurants and i called new york
city and they said no medical exemptions
period
and i tweeted that out all the same
activists were nowhere in sight no
longer replying no longer arguing they
could have replied with like wow i
didn't see that coming in fact i even d
i i sent messages to cameron caskey the
act the parkland activist because we had
interacted on the idea of medical
exemptions we were talking i tweeted
about google
mandating uh vaccines and said i wonder
how many people are gonna are gonna quit
their jobs or lose their jobs and he
said he was he responded there's about
to be a lot of openings for people who
aren't stupid and then i was like some
people have medical issues bro and he's
like well there will be exemptions so
when this thing with new york happened i
just i in good faith i was like hey just
wanted you to see this because i know we
had interacted on it no response because
these people aren't acting in good faith
if i come out and say something like you
know joe biden should do x and then
someone argues with me and then joe
biden goes and does x i'll be like well
you know i should i got to eat my words
joe biden just did it but that you don't
see that from most tribalists and you
look at look at what's happening
imminently to the military now we've got
hundreds of thousands of people in the
military who are not vaccinated
and we're going around
celebrating our heroes in afghanistan
and you know and
you know the left and the right are both
like oh my god you know we love the
military the military but then
they're gonna turn around in a week or
two and a whole bunch of those people
are gonna what be called caught up in
charges court-martialed or get some sort
of you know pushed out of the military
at a time when our military can't afford
it and all these people who said they
were great just like they said the
frontline healthcare workers oh my god
we love the nurses and the doctors going
at risk in their lives oh wait they're
not getting the vaccine that's it for
them and they literally throw them out
of a moving car
and and so you know it's the
inconsistency the person person who
doesn't get the vaccine to chose for
whatever reason doesn't get the vaccine
if they're out there risking their life
for their country or or saving lives and
as a health care worker they're still
the same darn person
that was doing that thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you